نانسي اعلنت عدم سعيها مجددا لقياده الحزب
الديمقراطي
بالكونجرس الامريكي ما فتح الباب امام
الطامحين لخلافتها رئيسه مجلس النواب
الحاليه تنتهي ولايتها بحلول لي يناير
المقبل ويبدا بعدها الحزب في مرحله اعاده
رسم مسار جديد لديمقراطيين لاول مره منذ
عقود المسار الجديد سيبدا مع تراجع اول
ثلاث قيادات برلمانيه نانسي بيلوسي وابرز
شخصيتين في الكونجرس بعدها نتحدث عن ثاني
هوير وعن جينز كليبر اذا نتحدث عن هذين
عده شخصيات اعلنت عن ترشحها للمناصب
القياديه منهم حكيم جفريز اذا نتحدث عن
حكيم جافريز وكذلك ايضا عن كافرن كلارك
وعن بيت اجيلار هم الذين عبروا عن سعيهم
بشغل المناصب القياديه مع رحيل الحرس
القديم
المرشحون الثلاثه يتميزون بعمر اصغر من
القيادات الحاليه فهم اقل من 60 عاما من
العمر ايضا التنوع العرقي والجنسي قد يمثل
دعما لهم
حكيم جافريز مرشح لان يكون اول شخص من
اصول افريقيه في منصب قيادي بالحزبين في
اي من مجلسي الكونجرس وايضا بوجود كافرين
كلارك سيضمن الحزب وجود سيده في قيادته
اما الطرف الثالث
سيكون ثاني مشرع من اصل لاتينيه تراس
المؤتمر الحزبي اذا تم انتخابه هذا الشهر
واشنطن بوست التقط باكثر من 20 من اعضاء
الكونجرس عند الحزب الديمقراطي وعبره عن
تفائلهم بشان الجيل الجديد من القاده
المتوقع ان يتولى زمام الامور
عذرا لكن ظلال ستبقى فوق القياده الجديده
فبحسب الصحيفه يدرك الديمقراطيون في مجلس
النواب باغلبيه ساحقه انه لا يوجد زعيم
واحد في الجيل الجديد يمكن ان يكون بالنفس
قوه بروسيا بنفس قدرتها على تحقيق نتائج
تشريعيه من خلال اقناع الاعضاء من خلال
دفعهم في الاتجاه المطلوب بدون القبضه
المشدده لقياده بيلوسي يتخوف الحزب من ان
يخلق الواقع الجديد سيناريو لا يمكن فيه
لاحد التحكم في مطالب الاعضاء احد اعضاء
كونغرس الذين تحدثوا الى واشنطن بوست
شريطه عدم الكشف عن نسمه قال انه لم يعش
النواب في حاله خوف من رئيس مجلس النواب
فربما تخرج الامور عن السيطره هنا كانت
اهميه وير العديد من الديمقراطيين ان
التغيير مخاطره ولكن تستحق المجازه
لسامهم مما وصفه بالحكم من اعلى الى اسفل
وهم يبحثون عن قاده الجد ينخرطون في كثير
من الاحيان مع الاجنحه المختلفه للحزب في
الكونجرس
الثلاثي القيادي المرتقب في الكونجرس
المقبل جافريز وكلارك واجيلار قضوا الكثير
من الوقت خلال الفتره الماضيه في التقويه
العلاقات مع اعضاء الحزب واكدوا انهم
سيعتمدون على نقاط القوه لبعضهم البعض
لتقريب الجامع وجوهات النظر على طاوله
الحوار الداخليه في الحزب وفي حين يوجد
حماس كبير للمسار الجديد للحزب عبر العديد
من الاعضاء الديمقراطيين عن سعادتهم لسماع
ان الحرس القديم سيظل موجوده في الفتره
المقبله للاخذ بلاد القياد الجديده على
امل العوده بعد عامين لاستعاده السيطره
على مجلس النواب
ايقونات